The next best predictor of lifetime
success is conscientiousness,
while so and of the,
of the two aspects of conscientiousness
say orderliness and industriousness.
The better predictor is industriousness.
So the question is,
well,
what can you do about your
industriousness?
And the answer to that is,
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component,
but you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and I
think the best micro habits.
This is partly to do with this future
authoring program processes.
I think the best thing you can do with
regards to your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself.
Goals that you actually value and the
future authoring program helps people do
that and basically it does a situational
analysis of it helps you do a
situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis I would
say.
And so the questions are something like,
well,
alright,
you're going to have to put some effort
into your life and you need to be
motivated to do that.
And so what are the potential sources of
motivation?
You could think about them in the big
five manner.
If you're extroverted,
you want friends,
if you're agreeable,
you want an intimate relationship.
If you're disagreeable,
you want to win competitions.
If you're open,
you want to engage in creative activity.
If you're high in neuroticism,
you want security.
Okay?
So those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own,
you know,
your own personality.
But then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across.
And so we ask people about,
well,
you know,
if you could have your life the way you
wanted it in three to five years,
if you were taking care of yourself
properly,
you know,
what would you want from your
friendships?
What would you want from your intimate
relationship?
How would you like to structure your
family?
What do you want for your career?
Well,
how are you going to use your time
outside of your job and how are you
going to regulate your mental,
physical,
mental,
and physical health,
and maybe also your drug and alcohol
use.
Because that's,
that's a good place to Auger down,
you know,
because alcoholism,
for example,
wipes out,
you know,
five to 10 percent of people,
so you want to keep that under control
and then,
and then so maybe you know,
you,
you develop a vision of what your life,
what you would like your life to be and
that associates the so the goal,
once the goal is established and then
you break down the goal into micro
processes that you could implement the
microprocesses become rewarding in
proportion in relation to there a causal
association with the goal and that
tangles in your,
your incentive reward system.
We talked about the dopaminergic
incentive reward system and that's the
thing that keeps you moving forward and
the way it works is that it works better
if it produces positive emotion.
When it can see you moving towards a
valued goal,
okay,
well what's the implication of that?
Better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle,
the more the micro processes associated
with that goal start to take on a
positive charge.
And so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day,
you're ready to go,
and so as far as I can tell,
what you do is you specify your longterm
ideal.
Maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding.
Because that's also useful.
You specify your goal.
You do that,
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual.
You want.
You want to specify goals that make you
say,
Oh,
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts,
it would clearly be worthwhile.
Because the question always is,
why do something?
Because doing nothing is easy.
You just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy.
The question is why would you ever do
anything?
And the answer that has to be because
you've determined by some means that
it's worthwhile.
And then the next question might be,
well,
where should you look for worthwhile
things?
And one would be while you can consult
your own temperament,
and the other would be,
while you kind of look at how,
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan.
Look,
look what you do,
a structural analysis of the
subcomponents of human existence and
already did that.
You need a family,
you need friends,
like you don't need to have all of these
things,
but you better have most of them.
Family,
friends,
career,
educational goals,
plans for time outside of work,
attention to your mental and physical
health,
etc.
You know those are,
that's what life is about.
And if You don't have any of those
things,
well then all you've got left is misery
and suffering.
So that's,
that's a bad,
that's a bad deal for you.
So,
so once you,
once you set up that goal structure,
let's say,
and that's really in many,
in many ways,
that's what you should be doing at
universities is that's exactly what you
should be doing,
is trying to figure out who it is that
you're trying to be.
Right?
And you aim at that and then use
everything you learned as a means of
building that person that you want to
be.
And and I really mean want to be.
I don't mean should be even those
things.
Those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly,
and this is back down to the micro
routine analysis.
So I started saying,
well,
you're going to try to make yourself
more industrious.
Okay?
Number one,
specify your damn goals because how are
you going to hit something if you don't
know what it is that isn't going to
happen?
And often people won't specify their
goals too because they don't like to
specify conditions for failure.
So if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy,
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well,
then you don't know when you fail.
And people might say,
well,
I really don't want to know when I fail
because that's painful,
so I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail.
ThAt's fine,
except you'll fail all the time.
Then you just won't know it until you
failed so badly that you're done and
that can easily happen by the time
you're 40,
so,
so I would recommend that you don't let
that happen.
So that's willful blindness,
right?
You could have known but you chose not
to.
Okay.
So once you get your goal structure set
up,
you think,
okay,
if I could have this life looks like
that might be worth living despite the
fact that it's going to be,
you know,
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that.
Obviously the goal is to have a vision
for your life such that all things
considered that justifies your effort.
Okay,
so then what do you do?
Well then then you turn down to the
micro routines.
It's like,
okay,
well this is what I'm aiming for.
How does that instantiate itself day to
day,
week to week,
month to month.
And that's where something like a
schedule can be unbelievably useful.
google calendar,
it's like make a damn schedule and stick
to it.
Okay.
So what's the rule with the schedule?
It's not a bloody prison.
That's the first thing that people do
wrong.
He said,
well,
I don't like to follow a schedule.
It was like,
well,
what kind of schedule are you setting
up?
Well,
I,
I have to do this.
Then I have to do this.
Then I have to do this,
and then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do?
It's like wrong.
Set the damn schedule up so that you
have the day you want.
That's the trick.
It's like,
okay,
I've got tomorrow.
If I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking,
what would it look like?
Well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense,
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day,
you're not in worse shape than you were
at the beginning of the day,
right?
Because that's a stupid day.
If you have a bunch of thoSe in a row,
you just dig,
dig yourself a hole and then you bury
yourself in.
It's like,
sorry,
that's just not a good strategy,
bad strategy.
So maybe 20 percent of your day has to
be responsibility and obligation or
maybe it's more than that,
depending on how far behind you are,
but even that you can.
You can ask yourself,
okay,
well I've got these responsibilities.
I have to schedule the damn things in.
What's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward?
And you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you.
It'S like,
okay,
you got to work tomorrow.
Okay,
so I want you to work tomorrow.
And you might say,
okay,
well what are you going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you.
While you could ask yourself that,
you know,
maybe you do an hour of of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes.
I don't know,
whatever turns your crank man,
but you know,
you have to negotiate with yourself and
not tyrannized yourself.
Like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for,
that you would like to be productive and
have a good life,
and that's how you make the schedule.
It's like,
and then you look at the day and you
think,
well,
if I had that day,
that'd be good.
Great.
You know,
and you,
you're useless and horrible,
so you'll probably only hit it with
about 70 percent accuracy,
but that beats the hell out of zero.
Right?
And if you hit it even with 50 percent
accuracy,
another rule is well,
aim for 51 percent the next week or 50
and a half percent for god's sake or
because you're,
you're going to hit that position where
things start to loop back positively in
spiral you upward and so,
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness is a plan a life
you'd like to have and you do that
partly by referring to social norms.
That's more or less rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale.
But the way other way you do that is by
having a little conversation with
yourself about as if you don't really
know who you are,
because you know what you're like.
You won't do what you're told,
you won't do what you tell yourself to
do.
You must have noticed that it's like
you're a bad employee and a worse boss
and both of those work for you.
You don't know what you want to do.
And then when you tell yourself what to
do,
you don't do it anyways.
You should fire yourself and find
someone else to beat.
But,
but you know what?
My point is that you have to understand
that you're not your own servant,
so to speak.
You're someone that you have to
negotiate with and someone that you want
to present the opportunity of having a
good life too.
And that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much.
So you know,
they're always like cracking the whip
and then procrastinating and cracking
the whip and then procrastinating.
And it's like,
god,
it's so boring and such a pathetic way
of spending your time.
And you know what that's like because
you probably waste like six hours a day
and I think we did an economic
calculation about that awhile back,
right?
Your time is probably worth 50 bucks an
hour,
something like that.
I mean,
you're not getting paid that now,
but you're young.
And so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future.
so,
so let's say it's 50 bucks an hour,
which is perfectly reasonable.
So if you waste six hours a day and you
are,
then you're wasting about $2,000
a week or about $100,000
a year.
So like go ahead.
But that's what it's costing you every
hour.
And you need to know what your damn time
is worth.
So let's say it's not 50 bucks,
it's 30,
whatever.
Maybe it's 100,
it's somewhere in that range.
One of the things you should be asking
yourself is when you spend an hour was
that,
well,
what have I paid someone 50 bucks to
have had that hour?
And if the answer is no,
it's like,
well,
maybe you should do something else with
your time.
And it depends on whether or not you
think that your time is worthwhile.
But the funny thing about not assuming
that is if you assume your time isn't
worthwhile,
what happens is you don't just sit
around sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility list bliss.
What you do is you suffer existentially.
And so that seems like a stupid
solution.